[Music]
[Applause]
mike florio knows all these things mike
who would benefit from leaking this
information about the contract and the
addendum with kyler murray
agents who represent other quarterbacks
basically that's how i got it
once the contract is signed it goes to
the league office it goes to the union
other people have access to it other
people will take it
copy and paste it
and send it to people like me
who would be interested in
writing a story about it talking about
it it's interesting it's news it's
unprecedented no one's ever had a clause
like this so that's how it gets out and
this was a failure by the team
and by the agent to understand
how the dominoes were going to fall this
is going to come out it's going to make
kyler murray look like he doesn't study
hard enough and it's going to make the
cardinals look worse for paying him all
that money
recognizing that they think he doesn't
study hard enough so it was a failure
across the board it's smart that they
got rid of it
and
now they hope they can repair the damage
dan this damage may be permanent it may
be a situation where a year or two from
now kyle murray just decides i want out
arizona that that it drives a wedge that
can never be repaired between player and
team
now what you're saying is an agent not
kyla murray's agent
gave you this contract or at least the
addendum or you had access to that
i'm always uncomfortable
delving into my very complicated high
level process for gathering information
as i fare it through dump dumpsters
looking for pieces of paper that i can
that i can put back together shredded
like in argo where they recollected all
that no
people who want stuff out will give it
to reporters and they have different
reasons for it but the agents have
access to all these companies have
access to these agents have access to
these contracts people with other teams
have access to these contracts people
who saw this contract
would want it to get out there
because they knew it was going to create
a mess
for murray his agent and the cardinals
there's going to be clear incentive to
get it out there that's the way this
business works people like to cause
problems for others it's competitive at
every level in every way however dan at
the same time that someone was giving it
to me with the idea that it's going to
be
put out there for people to see what it
is and reach their own conclusions i do
think murray's camp recognizing oh crap
this is going to be put out there maybe
by somebody who puts a negative spin on
it let's try to get it out there in a
way that puts a positive spin on it we
saw you in rap report of nfl media try
to put all due respect i like ian but it
was kind of a ridiculously positive spin
on this this unprecedented term that
required
kyla murray to put in four hours a week
during the season of film study so
there are different motivations and
different reasons but yeah information
gets put out there because people have a
broader agenda that they they want to
accomplish did kyler help himself
yesterday with that
uh unscheduled press conference
i don't know he helped himself or hurt
himself i just think that the
unscheduled press conference
highlights the problem the problem is
between him
and the team
if he's mad at anybody here
it's the team
and or his agent
somebody should have worked together to
realize what this was going to do and
who it was going to make look bad to the
extent that he believes it's
disrespectful to think that he doesn't
work hard enough that ultimately is on
michael bidwell the owner of the
cardinals because dan before monday
nobody was saying kyler murray doesn't
work hard enough nobody was questioning
whether it wasn't an issue it wasn't a
talking point the cardinals by insisting
on this clause
made it a thing they made it an issue
and yes the agent should have said no
but let me take up for eric burkhardt
here because yes he should have done
everything in his power to get michael
bidwell to take this clause out
but think about what happens if the
cardinals position is
we're not giving you this contract
unless you accept this term he walks
away from 46.1 million per year
he makes only 5 million this year
and kicks it forward to next year and
then who knows what happens next year
look what happened to baker mayfield
when he didn't get a contract in
cleveland before his fourth season it
could all fall apart and dan i guarantee
you
someone from the cardinals would have
leaked
to someone in the media
kyle murray walked away from 46 1
because he didn't want to agree to only
four hours a week
of film study
it would have made him look even worse
than the clause itself
made him look and that's what they were
looking at and that tells me that these
two sides should just not be doing
business together if that's how
dysfunctional it is what the hell are
you doing with a seven-year contractual
commitment
dk metcalf got paid by seattle what's
that mean for debo samuels contract well
it's very easy because it's the same
agent
tori dandy of caa representing both guys
you just you take it you take it into
jed york and you cross out
same price
yeah give me the same deal who do you
want who do you want out of those two
same price i want dk metcalf because i
think dk metcalf has untapped potential
because they don't use him the way that
they should this is one of sims big
criticisms of the seahawks it's just run
down the field and get open well i want
him to use him like they use debo in san
francisco he had three carries i think
in his career exactly he's more valuable
i think potentially than debo if you use
him like debo but i'd take either guy i
think either guy can transform an
offense and make up for a not great
quarterback but dan here's my hot take
on
the the dk metcalf contract
i'm stunned that the seahawks only asked
for a three-year extension on the
existing one-year deal
i i think that this is
a circumstantial piece of evidence that
his next contract will be for the next
owner of the team that this team is
going to be sold between now
and the time that dk medcast contract is
up for renegotiation okay that's my hot
tape okay i'd take yeah
as long as that's the fire truck and not
the police car
with that okay do you want in on our
drew lock over under touchdown passes
this year
do you want to be with fritzy
uh or do you want to be with the rest of
us now
pie to the face attached to this
by the way did you get your pi
is this double or nothing can i do a
double than nothing part of the face
when do you get your pie to the face
mike
seton bailed me out because
the whole thing was tom brady 49ers
quarterback week one
and as seaton pointed out until week one
actually arrives and tom brady's not the
quarterback of the 49ers the bet isn't
official okay so week one on their show
so monday
after that game after you know brady
plays
against the cowboys
then you'll do a pie to the face i'll do
part of the face okay here's the over
under touchdown passes for drew lock
this year
was it 19 fritzy yeah i said 19th so i
guess you're going 18 and a half okay so
would you go over under drew locke 19
touchdown passes this year i'm going to
go under okay because i think gino
smith's gonna be the week one starter i
think pete carroll
wants to prove that he can win with
russell wilson's backup
that wilson wanted out because he didn't
like the system he didn't like that they
weren't making him the center piece of
the offense and i think that i think
that geno smith is going to be the week
one starter as of right now okay so
you're going under all right i'll go on
fritzy went over
who's the worst team in the nfl
well
there are three teams in the afc that i
would call not contenders the jets the
jaguars and the texas
i would say probably the texans as of
right now because of their circumstance
if they're then in the nfc
you at least have a chance because
beyond the buccaneers the rams and the
packers it's wide open
i think it would probably be the texans
right now uh i i i still don't know
whether they're all in with davis mills
or whether this is just kind of a full
season tank to position themselves to
draft a franchise quarterback next year
and i have them as one of the teams dan
that i'm keeping an eye on maybe for
jimmy garoppolo i don't think they're
going to be able to trade garoppolo i
think he's going to get cut and then
somebody's going to make a move to try
to sign
mike florio pro football talk live
co-host uh lamar jackson
now you so you've got a couple of
contracts to play off of desean watson
kyler murray is lamar jackson going to
be the highest paid player in football
you know i used to say that he badly
needs an agent but
if the agent means you get a homework
clause in your contract maybe it is
better to be doing it
on your own dan it was so weird a year
ago the narrative was lamar is too busy
he's too focused on football and there
was a long period of time where the
ravens were ready and he wasn't now he
is but as john harbaugh the coach of the
team said yesterday he's kind of busy
he's in practice all day when do we
really work on this deal
i think there's a chance that the ravens
put the best offer they have on the
table and lamar says no thank you like
what happened 10 years ago with joe
flacco now flacco had an agent but the
ravens
said here's our best offer as flacco
entered the last year of his rookie
contract flacco said no thanks super
bowl win super bowl mvp highest paid
player in the nfl after that season i
think lamar may have to say no
in order to become the highest paid
player because right now aaron rodgers
is the highest at north of 50 million a
year i don't think they're going to go
that far and i think this whole
five-year full guarantee
the desean watson thing now the
cardinals didn't do it with kyle murray
i think one of the reasons is
the team doesn't have the ability to put
170 million in escrow because that's
what you have to do if you guarantee
that much money
but
maybe jackson pushes for that maybe he
pushes for something else the problem is
we don't have an agent as the go-between
it makes it so awkward for both sides i
think there's a good chance they just
don't get a deal done and it gets
delayed until after the season
the owner who is uh jeopardizing his
ownership more
daniel snyder stephen ross which one do
you think is running the risk of losing
his team
ross because i think the league would be
more inclined to go after him
then they would be to go after snyder i
think they're afraid of snyder i think
they know that he would fight in any
court in the land including courts in
other countries he had a pending lawsuit
in india for crying out loud over a
defamation claim that that he made ross
and we don't know
where this stands the investigation the
league was conducting into the
allegation from former dolphins coach
brian flores that ross was offering a
hundred thousand dollars per loss in
2019. i asked the league about it
recently no update well what
what's taking so long
you've got a small handful of people to
talk to brian flora as i'm told fully
cooperated with the league back in april
you've got potential corroborating
evidence at one point the league
reported through nfl network that
there's a unnamed witness that says yeah
i heard him say it so i i just think dan
if there wasn't litigation from brian
flores that specifically tied this
allegation to one of his theories
against the dolphins we'd probably have
a decision by now my point is this
if the league believes he didn't if we
ever get to the point where the league
says yeah he did it i think he's out and
i don't think they have any qualm about
fighting him because he won't fight back
the way snyder would and then brady
leaves tampa and then becomes the part
owner of the miami dolphins next well
well hey if stephen ross goes down bruce
beale may go down as well and beale is
the brady connection to the dolphins so
if that happens okay then brady's got to
go to the 49ers
in week one
yeah
thank you michael i can't say which year
yeah that may be my other way out of
this
uh by the way seton's working on his
kyler murray impersonation
[Laughter]
that's it
it sounded like beavis yes it did
exactly
yes i think that was butthead yes all
right thank you well done thank you it's
mike florian pro football talk live
co-host he's taking the under there
fritzi
drew lock he says lock won't even be
stopped
he's not a lock to start
how do you throw 19 touchdowns if you're
not even going to start